let's get the generic question out of
the way how did you how'd you first hear
about this project and and and what was
it that the most exciting about it I'd
heard that the tom-toms had sent you
know the smoke signals had been Woody
Allen was checking my availability which
caused me some excitement because he's
sort of been a bit of a soundtrack to my
life since I was pretty young I'm into
the 70s I'm you know when I was fairly
my exams I'd go and see Barry Allen film
or you know it was you know he has a
very specific way of operating this is
probably the script was the first piece
of hard copy I'd seen in decades so I
think and you know and I was in Italy I
have a house in Italy and it had to be
driven to my house and I was the person
who handed it to me personally waited
somewhere while I read it and I'm not
another fast reader and I like to sort
of mall on things for a while and maybe
take a couple of days but I was
conscious of this person sitting
somewhere who needed to get back and who
might be judging me for my you know the
pace in which I was going through it
anyway look to cut a long story short
yeah I read it I got I read it in five
minutes handed it back and promptly said
no I don't
hamish can I ask you there that they you
hear these stories about actors being
called in for the you know meeting with
Woody Allen and they often say it's
completely not what they expect it's a
very unique situation can you can you
explain what your experience meeting in
for the first time was yeah I asked
what's the material what's the character
what do we know I know it's hot rodded
in secrecy and they were like well we
we're not sure we think your character
is like a homebody maybe he's a
lumberjack
I was like so I should wear plaid they
were like yeah definitely go with plaid
so I took I didn't shave I wore my plant
to the meeting and would he you know I
waited in this dark room and then and I
had my you know my classical monologue
ready my contemporary comic monologue
ready
there was no materials but assumed he
would want to see something and he
walked in and he was like so we're
interested in you for this movie in the
South of France that's set in the 20s we
understand there might be some trouble
with your schedule as it no trouble at
all sir well then we'll see you there
and he walked out so I burnt my plaid
fired my representation and got to
France now my understanding is that what
he doesn't really do rehearsal is that
right so you guys where you just sort of
thrown right into the to the deep end
together was a kind of a intimidating
thing to go to work for for somebody
who's been making such great movies for
so long I'm just still reeling from the
fact that he'd got a meeting actually
finding out everybody got a meeting
apparently my god amazing it was it was
it was terrifying
some of us got to France before he did
you know he sort of parachuted in and we
we'd been there for three or four days
sort of freaking out in harmony and and
you know fear brings people together and
I think we formed you know that made us
a quite a tight group but we we were
guessing and it's like a lot of his
films it's it's dialogue based quite
heavy with dialogue and the idea that
because I'd had all these things about
him and they're people all sorts of
things get said then one of them was you
know he he doesn't direct he doesn't
rehearse he doesn't direct and he's very
retiring don't expect him ever to be
funny and well it's true he doesn't
rehearse I mean the first crack at the
lines that
I had were in front of a rolling camera
I mean it was action that was the first
word he said to me really cut nice to
meet you
oh you got nice to meet you know it's
some you know he's personable and polite
being in an incredibly shy way and you
know I was cautious about whether to
even ask questions well what was not
true
was did he doesn't direct because fairly
you know three minutes after the word
action was the word cut and then a
barrage of notes and the information
about what was wrong with what we just
done and then after about the thirtieth
take he sort of felt he had a couple of
prints he could work with which were the
whole scene was reshot on the last day
and then he did not make the final cut
of this movie and that was true the
whole first day but he did direct he
directed meticulously and he was
incredibly involved and I was really
surprised because I braced myself for
all this stuff about who you don't
expect to hear from him and I was
terrified because I had all this stuff
to say and I thought if we don't
rehearse and he doesn't direct I thought
you know I've got my it's all homework
you know I mean I my only interaction
with him on a personal level was was as
he was directing there's not a lot of
chitchat
did he ever like talk to you we talked
for a while
I gotta say that was like one of the
longest brunches of ever well but Hamish
is there in all seriousness though was
there you know one piece of an of
direction or guidance or anything that
he gave that was particularly helpful to
both of you starting with Hamish I mean
was there anything I'll tell you this he
said to me he was like well now I mean
after my first two takes he was like
well we have we have two your way and
you might be right and I might be wrong
but let's try one where it seems like
you like her and like there's like you
know just with the scintilla of romance
just like yeah you actually like her
okay let's try I mean that was just my
impression when I wrote it I might be
wrong again I found him like dead
charming and borderline flirty frankly
the way he gave direction and I really
liked it a lot I remember years ago when
I was contemplating playing a role that
was incredibly unsympathetic one of the
people who knew me best said you are so
really like that it would be a wonderful
opportunity for you just to take off any
masks you have and just to be as
unpleasant as you really are you should
go for it and it was like that with this
there were one of the notes because
Woody Allen's vocabulary is quite
extraordinary I mean nobody else has
ever said now I want you to do it take
expressing excessive contumely
and no one has used that word in my life
if I if in fact had I not played Hamlet
as a student I wouldn't even ever heard
it and I had to think for a second what
he was asking for but I mean basically
was that just give yourself up to being
an [ __ ] and it's wonderfully
liberating trying to win people over is
is difficult it's it's it puts pressure
you because all your you know your
supposed it assets are being called on
then if no one's really that sure they
have any and and so to say no throw that
out the window it's okay if they hate
you it's wonderful the other part of
words which I hadn't ever heard from a
director before but I suddenly kind of
it spiraled into a kind of retrospective
of my entire career was he just came up
after take and said that was
somnambulistic and I was so unfamiliar
with the use of the word that I for a
moment I was hoping it was a compliment